Where I come from
civil war and politics affects each family
in one way or another.
I’m no exception:
My father was assassinated when I was 5 years
old.
Since then I learned how to seek the truth,
to find it, to face it and tell it
no matter how difficult and unpopular.
And exactly this search brought me to journalism.
Now, in the Middle East, political actors
can be extremely influential in the media
business.
They use them to voice and defend their own
interests.
So you can imagine how difficult it is for a journalist
to be independent in such an environment.
My aim is to pursue the truth
by accurately verifying facts,
challenging common assumptions
and presenting the fullest version of the
truth
that I can deliver.